this is a production of cornell
university
good um before getting into the the
actual seminar i'd like to
acknowledge some of my
former graduate students and
and colleagues
ralph brown from university of guelph
that
did a lot of the work on
remote sensing in these projects
and then
javad hakimi mary jaczynski
matthew marciniak david letterhoff jim
wellworth
were all graduate students that worked
on a lot of these projects and
so i want to acknowledge their hard work
i thought it started off with a little
bit of a
just a funny slide just to
show you what my office sort of looked
like almost 30 years ago in summerland
after i left
cornell and the the point i wanted to
make about this was
you don't see a computer there in fact
you don't see anything electronic really
these offices that we were sitting in 30
years ago were not a whole lot different
from an office that you would have sat
in in the 1920s really
you know lots of paper a dial phone no
voice
no voice mail
no email
no computers
and uh
you can imagine just how far we have
come
in in the research field
in terms of our
reliance on electronics over the last 30
years
and you know if you look at my my office
now
i have
i haven't quite got the whole idea of
the paperless society
obviously
but the main thing is is this
and we all have computers
we all have voice mail
we all have cell phones
very often that take pictures
so there's been a tremendous reliance on
computers computers that help us write
computers that help us communicate
help us
analyze data
and a number of other things
and so without electronics uh it would
be a very very different world
and
electronics has helped us in
horticulture as well
and electronics has helped us in terms
of mapping
and
getting into a whole new
scheme of things that i refer to as
geomatics
use of gps
use of
gis
and uh and vineyard mapping and uh
horticultural mapping doesn't have to be
vineyards it can be orchards it could be
uh
agronomic crops and a whole bunch of
other things
so what what i'd like to talk a little
bit about today is
use of gps for
purposes of site and vine location
data acquisition and how we acquire data
whether it be from
vehicles like planes or or drones or
tethered balloons and we we've tried it
all
or from from the ground and there's uh
lots of ways of doing that
spectral meters there's something called
green seeker where you can take
lateral views of the canopy
and and collect spectral reflectance
data uh from from that
so there's all kinds of uh tools out
there that we can use
and then there's of course the the whole
data analysis and display what do we do
with all this data
and that's where
gis comes in and
arc is the main
gis program that is used throughout the
world now
when i first started with this in the
mid to late 90s there was a program
called map info and vertical mapper and
so i'm still most familiar with that so
i'm going to have to learn arc one of
these days probably before mary
jaczynski leaves because she's the ones
going to have to teach me
and then after this of course it's all
about data interpretation once you've
got a map
that's very nice but how do
all the different maps
integrate with each other
how can one variable relate to another
in terms of spatial variability and
things of that nature and so that's when
we start getting into
uh precision viticulture and making use
of this
to apply different treatments to
different parts of
individual blocks
and getting into things like micro
terroirs
so
what about just basic site location or
basic vine location this is where we use
uh
gps
in order to delineate blocks and to
geo-locate individual vines that we're
going to use for for
mapping and uh
if you go back 15 years there was not a
lot of people that had even heard a gps
but gps had been used for a few years
in agronomic crops and was being used
for for the sake of precision viticul or
precision agriculture in soybeans and
wheat and corn potatoes and things of
that nature but it really had not been
applied to
horticultural crops at that point
this is what we can do this is a
vineyard block this is a about a 10-acre
riesling block and those different uh
numbers on there are elevations
and what it's showing you pretty well is
uh just some high and low elevations i i
take it this is a uh
yeah there we are
uh so these
kind of red and orange areas are the
highest elevation zones
in the block and then we've got this
kind of a a little bit of a trough in
here and then it goes down
into a low elevation zone here
and these are all the individual vines
that we took data from and we collected
a whole layer cake of maps
from this particular block
on on yield and vine size and and bricks
and titratable acidity and a whole bunch
of other things and we can see all the
different relationships between all
these different variables spatially and
see what variables happen to correlate
with which with uh with other variables
a lot of these data can be collected
from uh not just from the ground but
from the air and
when i was doing some work with with dr
brown from university of guelph we were
using
a small
plane such as this with a large
camera inside and we took a
uh
photographs from from the air from this
uh but there's lots lots of other things
that you can use and uh there are now
different kinds of drones and unmanned
um
um objects out there that you can use
and attach small cameras to these and
they can collect uh data for you
they're not cheap
um but there are some companies out
there that are now making use of these
these drones and
unmanned objects
and then you can collect things from the
ground this is in champaign at a place
called plum cook
and
this little
tractor here has got a green seeker
mounted to it
and a
multi-spectral camera and they take it
through the
uh the vineyards
and create these different maps
eventually from all the the data that
they collect and what you're seeing in
the background here are a whole bunch of
different maps that they've created
on
spectral effects of the leaves and
potential anthocyanins in the uh in the
fruit and a number of other things
and this is just a a close-up this is
the the green seeker
that's measuring spectral reflectance
and
here we have a
a multi-spectral camera you can see all
the different lenses in there and that's
mounted and then they take a whole
series of lateral images throughout the
vineyard and the same thing can happen
uh if you want to in in orchards and
things like that might be difficult in
uh traditional apple archers but i would
say in
something like a
a super spindle
or or some of the more modern
trellised orchards it would work very
very well
the type of data that you collect isn't
just spectral reflectance you can
collect everything and
take all of these data and relate it to
some of the spectral data that you're
collecting so it could be
things like
vine water status and soil water status
and we've done a lot of work like that
of course yield
basic fruit composition some some
specialized fruit compositions such as
terpenes and
things like riesling
or
anthocyanins and phenolics and things of
that nature that you could collect for
red wine varieties
and then there's the whole
series of soil and
vine composition parameters you might
want to collect whether it's soil
texture soil composition
petiole composition and so on and so
forth so you can see that you could
create this
multi-layered
uh set of
maps just to see
where you're getting uh different
relationships between all these
different variables
and then you need to manipulate this
data somehow so once you've got all this
data
using things like leaf water potential
and and vine size and soil texture
as basically treatments
and zones within these different uh
vineyard blocks and then you can look at
these different categories and see how
they might impact
um
wine composition and wine quality and
we've done a lot of that over the years
and then of course looking at
correlations between the variables and
spatial correlations
and then the important thing is temporal
stability
are these different zones going to be
stable over time year after year after
year they're going to bounce around
and it's very important especially if
you're going to be
trying to use some sort of precision
agriculture that you have
temporally stable zones
year after year
so these uh for instances
are one way of displaying the data these
are some
maps that were created from greenseeker
at plumecook
vineyard in
champaign
i was over there in in june
and so there's a whole bunch of
different things
this one is a
nitrogen status here
unfortunately i've got my glasses on but
you can probably read some of these
yourself
particularly if you understand french
but in some cases there's things like
anthocyanins and and a number of other
things that they can use and
look at some of the different zones
high nitrogen zones here lower nitrogen
zones
in in this area and then you can
take
precision viticulture and you can try to
smooth things out and get rid of some of
that
instability and
some of that variability that you're
finding in those different blocks
with remote sensing
generally what we were doing was taking
aerial flyovers to collect uh
multi-spectral data
and then we would take also some
multi-spectral data from the ground in
order to
not just compare but also to verify the
the data that we were collecting from
the air and and then we would need to
manipulate this data
as you can imagine there's a lot of data
to collect and so we need to use some
specialized software in order to take
those pixels
and turn those pixels into maps
and very often if you happen to have
canopy as well as ground cover you need
to get rid of all those pixels that are
ground cover so that you just have the
canopy data to
manipulate and map otherwise
you're essentially going to have green
data all the way across works very well
in australia where it's all
tilled in between the rows and the only
green you have
is going to be the uh
the grapevine canopies but in
new york state and ontario and other
parts of uh
especially eastern north america you've
got that
ground cover crop that you have to deal
with
and this is a example from one of my
former graduate students
he's got some different
blocks here that
he was trying to extract what we call
ndvi data which is normalized difference
vegetation index
is based on
spectral reflectance in the the green
range
and in the the near infrared range
and so he
acquired these different images and then
got rid of the
cover crop
pixels like this and then from there
created this
actual ndvi map and you can see that
it's a
fairly homogeneous throughout but
there's some
zones here of higher ndvi
and a small area here where there's
lower ndvi
and why do you use this ndvi well
because it can relate very closely to
things that we're
interested in and we feel it are
important these are some
data from
andrew lamb at all from australia and
you're seeing some
relationships here between
inverse relationships between ndvi and
things like phenolics
anthocyanins color and things of that
nature so generally these low ndvi areas
are typically
related to lower vigor
lower yield and so consequently
higher color
and higher phenolics
all right
move on talk a little bit about
data interpretation
and precision viticulture
so precision viticulture
basically how has it been used thus far
it hasn't been something that's been
popular and a lot of that is is that
it takes time and you usually need to
have a person that is dedicated
to collecting these data and
interpreting these data for you it's not
something that as a grower
it's something you're going to be able
to do in your spare time i know my my ex
student david letterhoff was hired
specifically by
a winemaker in
british columbia and that's what he does
he does only precision viticulture and
only data collection and interpretation
so it's going to involve gps in order to
delineate the shapes of blocks to
geo locate vines
and things like that
and then of course you're going to need
to have gis software in order to manage
these data create the maps and help you
look at interrelationships between all
these different variables that you're
mapping
with agronomic crops
gps monitors have been
installed on things like combines
of our other harvesting equipment so
that you can very precisely map yield
and then go in there after the following
year
and try to smooth out some of those
low yielding areas by
adding a little bit more fertilizer
etcetera to some of those low yielding
areas a little bit less fertilizer to
some of those higher yielding areas
and so you can get some very precise uh
very location specific
yield maps that will help you do that
and
it might not just simply be
fertilizer rates it might be things like
inoculum rates in the case of soybeans
it could be seeding rates lime
application and so on and so forth
and i'll have to say that that's what i
thought i was going to do
when i first
started to get
interested in this and started to get
familiar with gps and things like that
but i realize that
in in viticulture it's not going to be
about trying to smooth out the the bumps
in the road and to try to get
the low areas up to higher areas and the
higher areas down the lower ones but
as much as just mapping a particular
vineyard block and then maybe creating
micro terroir based wines
and
embracing that kind of
uh variability that we happen to have in
a in a large vineyard block there's
nothing wrong with that
uh so in viticulture we're taking these
data we're
creating these maps
and
uh seeing what we get and then seeing if
we might be able to
make use of this data
and uh create other
um
vineyard specific wines that might
actually be block specific wines
so a lot of that's going to be
primarily for economic gain
another
look at some some maps from an
australian vineyard this is from some of
rob bramley's work
who's been doing quite a bit of work
with precision viticulture over the
years
this first one on the on the right or on
the left hand side rather
from the margaret river
showing a cabernet sauvignon block and
you can see some
low yielding areas here some higher
yielding areas in here and what they did
was they
separated
this fruit
in accordance to yield
and then produce different wines from uh
from the different yielding areas and
produce very different wines so this
might have been something that would go
into
say a 35 or 40 dollar bottle of wine
and some of this stuff
may have gone into yellowtail or
something like that and so they've been
able to produce these different whys and
we're trying to do the same in niagara
here's an example of how they were able
to use
gps uh to see how their pest control
practices have been uh
working and see how effective they are
and so these are botrytis severity maps
you can see some areas where it's very
severe over in this area
and some area areas where it's not quite
as severe
uh over here so obviously they're going
to need to
maybe bump up their their spray program
in some parts of this particular block
so on sites to be planted how can you
use this stuff well basically
you've got
um a bare canvas
so you you want to take lots of soil
samples obviously you can very precisely
map that land in terms of things like
soil texture
and mineral composition and slope and
a number of other variables such as that
and if you're seeing a lot of
variability you might say well i think i
might want to plant this end of the
vineyard
um with a different root stock maybe i
want to plant this end of the vineyard
with
something like so4 because it's a heavy
clay i need something that's going to
bust through that clay
uh at this end of the soil i've got sand
i i think maybe i'll uh use something
like 3309 or
riparia glower or something like that
and
you can use this information to
make choices in terms of not just root
stock but also
planting density
possibly even trellis system if you're
expecting one end of this
the vineyard to uh to be a lot more uh
vigorous you might want to use scott
henry at that end of the vineyard and
you might want to use just a standard
vsp
at the other end so there's a lot of
things and a lot of
different decisions that you can make
once you have this information and once
it's mapped
here's a here's an example um
this is a vineyard called chateau de
charm in
saint david's near niagara in the lake
these are two
side by side
chardonnay blocks
one as you can see is very high in sand
we've got about 72 to 82 percent sand in
here
and then over here it's mostly clay they
planted it all the same
they probably could have planted this at
a different planting density and given
the vines a little more room
and planted these a little bit tighter
so there were things that could have
been done
with
had they had this information right from
the get-go
on established sites there are a lot of
things you can do as well um
things can be precisely mapped of course
and you can still get all of that soil
data but you can get a lot of other
things you can delineate management
zones
once you know what the yield is what
what the vine size is and things like
that
you might be able to
implement implement some variable rate
technology as a result but the other
thing is is that if you
have some very clear differences in one
part of a block versus another you can
create two different products and those
two different products could
as i say
be used for economic gain you could
produce a very very high-end wine versus
something that's
more like a fifteen dollar bottle of
wine
here's an example
uh this is uh where we were mapping uh
flavor compounds in riesling
and this is at the cave spring vineyards
and these uh orange zones here orange
and yellow zones happen to be the areas
um where we were getting the highest
terpene
values
in the uh the riesling and there did
seem to be some temporal consistency
depending on year once we got into 2007
here
there happened to be a little bit larger
area with very high terpenes be because
it happened to be a dry air uh season
berries were smaller a little more
concentrated and so the
the high flavor zone
actually increased in size but generally
we're seeing
the same kind of temporal consistency so
had this company had this information
they might have wanted to go in and try
to
pick one zone like this
here or here and create a couple of
different
products as a consequence
why isn't it being used well like most
things in horticulture it's money
and it does take
time to collect all these data
and variable rate technology of course
isn't cheap we've had a couple of
growers that have tried to implement
some variable rate technology with
yield monitors on their harvesters and
things like that
and they've given it up mainly because
of cost
how however we could still
collect the data and possibly create
different products as a result
of that
the other thing is is the whole temporal
stability issue
here's an example of why it sometimes
doesn't work
my colleague joan davenport in
washington state did some work with the
yield monitor in concord vineyard
and so it's four different years where
they've got a yield monitor mounted on a
mechanical harvester
and
these
kind of red and yellow zones in this
block
represent the highest yielding areas
within that block
and then we get to the following year
and suddenly
the yield has dropped considerably and
the
pattern of the yield is is completely
different and then we go to the
following year and it's different once
again
and different
in in 2000 so we don't have that
temporal stability and without that we
can't really implement any kind of
variable rate technology doesn't always
happen this way
but very often it does
and this is one case where it does this
is a
block in niagara in the lake near where
i live
and
these yellow and orange zones happen to
be the highest yielding zone so over a
five year period for the most part we
were getting
high yielding zones in this
upper
part of the block and lower yielding
zones down here and it's going to bounce
around a little bit depending on what
kind of a year it is precipitation
patterns
things things of that nature
and you can also get spatial
stability or temp temporal stability in
things like bricks and uh and other
things this is another vineyard and
these uh
yellow and orange zones happen to be the
highest bricks zones as well and they
seem to
be relatively temporally stable
a little bit larger area here in 2002
because it happened to be a hot uh dry
summer so it expanded it's a little bit
smaller here but generally you're
getting that temporal stability and in
all of these graphs the scales are
different between here
yeah the scales are different equal
segments yeah within the range for each
year
that's right what we did that's a good
question what we did was uh for for all
of the data we just asked uh
the mapping program to give us uh
six different
uh
individual
denominations and so there was going to
be some difference so there are higher
bricks here for instance versus
a year such as 2001
so there there are some some differences
there
okay uh
move on talk a little bit about
geomatics on a regional basis before i
move on and talk about
micro terroirs and things like that this
is something you might recognize this is
seneca lake
and this is some some data from from bob
seam so i acknowledge bob seen
what he's got here is uh
based on a whole bunch of uh
weather stations
uh along seneca lake
and uh this is the christmas massacre of
1980. so all of these uh pink zones here
on the west side of seneca lake
represent cold areas
just before and during the christmas
massacre
and then after that
that cold air moved across seneca lake
because seneca lake of course doesn't
freeze it picked up some some warm air
uh crossing that lake
and then this blue area here
is some
slightly warmed air
that
that we see on this side of seneca lake
but then once that air moved on
and got further away from the lake it
picked up more cold air from the uh
as a result of continentality and you
see you've got cold air
over here so it just shows the effect of
seneca lake on a regional basis even in
1980 where we had uh temperatures close
to minus 30.
and there's
uh i think that was fahrenheit wasn't it
it was cold
yeah
i remember it being very cold
and this is something that you can do of
course and there's just growing degree
days in the napa valley and some of paul
skinner's work
uh you can see uh slightly lower growing
degree days down here because of the the
influence of san francisco bay
and as you get further up uh
napa valley you're getting into some
higher growing degree days
and then uh drops a little bit once you
get up around calistoga because you're
higher elevation and uh and so on and so
forth so that's another way you can make
use of
multiple uh
weather stations
and you can map growing degree days and
things like that
um
what i like to spend most of the rest of
this talk on is geomatics site
and uh
mapping things like yield and vine size
and water status
here's an example of a micro terroir
this is desolate in switzerland and
this is uh next to lausanne in in
western switzerland
and all of these different vineyards
up and down this uh hillside here
it's all chassella
the
age of the vines is relatively similar
but because of elevation and a number of
other things
these are all different terroirs and
they actually make different wines
depending on where
along this hillside
you're picking those chassella and they
are distinctly different if you go into
some of the wineries there where you can
taste some of these different wines it's
quite incredible it's a
real educational experience
so this is the kind of thing
what we wanted to look at and this is
going back to the the same riesling
vineyard that i showed you near the
beginning this is the saint urban
vineyard
and
what we're seeing here are differences
in vine size a high vine size zone here
low vine size zone
in this area
and in many cases these uh vine size or
vigor zones can be related to things
like yield
bricks
flavor and a number of other things
here's our friend shadow de charm this
is these are different yield zones
and those are those two two chardonnay
blocks side by side
a low yielding zone here in that sandy
block
and a high yielding zone
next door to it in that
heavy clay block
and then this jumped back and forth
unfortunately over over the period of
the four years we were collecting data
and then the other thing is is
collecting flavor data and mapping
flavor
and wouldn't that be great if you could
map flavor and create different wines
because you know
the potential flavor from from the
different zones in that particular block
so high flavor zone here
and a relatively lower flavor zone over
on this side
this is a way that
it has been used
commercially and this is some data from
mark greenspan when he was working for
gallo
back about 10 years ago where he went in
and used a number of different things
leaf water potential
vine size
ndvi data and
combined all of these and created some
some maps from this
hillside zinfandel vineyard
and created a
low vigor zone and a high vigor zone and
so
this low bigger zone went into their
35
sonoma reserve and their
high vigor zone that probably went into
either rose or barefoot or something
like that
so different different products from the
from the same block based on
information and just knowing
what you have there and the more data
you can collect
the more money you can make basically
from a given vineyard block
um
i
spent a moment just going back to how i
got into this in the first place
when i was working in
bc in the the early 90s
working with a geologist and did some
zoning
work but this was before gps so we were
just using a
transit and uh
trying to do everything using uh
just old-fashioned uh
elevations and
leaf layer numbers and bricks and ta and
ph and
use kriegging
and
mapped all these different variables and
try to create some different zones from
uh from a small vineyard
and then in the
later 90s
we had an 85 acre
vineyard multi-variety vineyard on the
hillside
and
used gps and gis to map a whole bunch of
different variables
so there's one example of
some of the work we did
pre-gps
we had about 200 different uh
vines that we took uh samples from in
this vigorous geoverse demeanor vineyard
next to skaha lake in
penticton bc
uh you can see the the vigor there and
what we were trying to do is look at uh
different brick zones
and then
once we had those brics data try to
create some different management zones
based on these brics data
and that was all as i say pre-gps days
and then with
the stuff at paradise
vineyard we actually did have some
some geomatic tools you can
get an idea of
this is uh
lake okanagan here so it was a
steep hillside vineyard with a lot of
different ravines and things like that
all through there so we had some major
variability throughout this
this vineyard in terms of
not just elevation but
things like vine size and yield and
bricks and ta and ph and
all the different
soil and petiole variables as well
all right move on i'll talk a little bit
about geomatics of water status which
was some uh work that was uh
done starting in 2005
some work by jim wilworth that's now our
extension viticulturist
2005 to 11 and uh
javad hakimi who worked at the same time
but on cabernet franc
what we did was
we chose 10 different sites throughout
the niagara peninsula there's lake
ontario here
each of these sites represented a
specific
sub-appellation so we had 10 different
sub-appellations throughout there and
tried to pick out
representative vineyards
in each of those different
sub-appellations for both riesling and
cabernet franc
and ran this project over a three-year
period mapped things such as
leaf water potential and and soil
moisture
and went in there on a
bi-weekly basis to collect these data
and then in the in the fall collect data
on uh
things such
as you know clusters per vine and yield
and uh
standard berry composition
and in uh riesling we were collecting
terpenes
for the berries and for the cabernet
franc
phenolics anthocyanins and color and
things of that nature
and this gives you some idea
walk you through
one site for riesling to just give you
some idea what we were finding
and this is the myers vineyard on the
lake
here we have leaf water potential so the
one thing to point out
we've got low leaf water potential here
so this was
the southern end of the vineyard and it
was
somewhat underwater stress each year
and then
higher leaf water potential in the
northern end of the vineyard
nice temporal stability we were glad to
see this
you'll notice that the the numbers are a
little bit different uh
2007 we were getting numbers in the uh
minus 12 to almost minus 13 range it was
a a dry year and it was a they were not
quite as low
in 2005 and 2006.
now we start to see
how these relate to other things that
are important
first of all
up here where we have the
higher leaf water potential we've also
got higher soil moisture
and we've also got higher vine size so
more vigor
higher soil moisture
higher leaf water potential so already
some nice relationships
as we move on here's our leaf water
potential again
so
high leaf water potential low
and up here we're getting higher berry
weights lower berry weights down here
and
down here where we're getting the lower
berry weights we're also getting
higher brix values
now this is where it gets i think quite
compelling this is a different site uh
because it happens to show the
relationships a little bit better and
these are leaf water potentials here
um 05 to o7
and these are the the lower leaf water
potential zones here that are
for the most part temporally stable
and you can see the potentially volatile
terpenes that line up
um
very nicely with these uh lower leaf
water potentials
so this guy paul boss this shadow
descharm has in fact created some
different
wine products
from this particular block
based on these data and so he's quite
excited and quite happy with these data
five minutes okay no problem
talk fast
um
so when we look at some of the the wine
and look at sensory
over on this side this is pls analysis
partially squares analysis we see what's
related things like water potential soil
moisture
sand content berry weight vine size
basically that was 75 percent
of the data set and
that's basically
the basis for terroir right there and
we're getting very different wines
that are associated with the high soil
moisture high water potential
so things are high in citrus and mineral
but also
vegetal and things like that over on
this side
a little bit more
peach apple uh baking spice and things
of that nature so we're getting very
different wines depending on whether
we've got
high or low soil moisture
so that to me has got a lot to do with
what terroir is all about the other
thing is we were able to to look at this
on a regional basis as well
because we had all those different sub
appellations we look at
some of these different
zones here's
some lakeshore vineyards right here
that were associated with mineral citrus
vegetal and things like that
and some of the
other areas the some of the bench areas
over here
that were associated more with baking
spice and tropical fruit and things of
that nature so there did seem to be some
um
truth to the the sub-appellation i don't
think there's ten of them but there's
probably at least three anyway
all right a few
uh comments about cabernet franc
essentially the same project
you can see some of the relationships
here
things like percent clay and
perhaps not
any surprise to you it got
a nice relationship to things like
calcium and potassium and
things like base saturation and soil ph
so there are a lot of
spatial relationships here
for the most part uh temporal stability
um
this is uh soil moisture and you can see
especially in 0.6 and 07 those soil
moisture zones were were almost mirror
images of each other not so much 2005
and i'm not sure why that is
i'll walk you through
shadow de charm these are
low water status zones here
in the the upper part of this block in
the north
and as you
look at some of the other variables you
can see that things such as for instance
leaf water potential
is related to lower berry weights
higher bricks higher anthocyanins
higher phenols
and things of that nature so once you
you know some of this information you
can have a pretty good idea of
what you might get in terms of some
some variables that that really mean
something to you
and pls once again we got high water
status over here low water status over
here associated with
color and red fruit and phenols and
things like that high water status
associated with
in particular uh bitterness and green
fruit and and
things of that nature
and once again we did some regional
assessment here
and we look at
these particular blocks
these four
are all waterfront
properties so they're all associated
with either lake ontario
or the niagara river so cooler sites and
these are all associated with things
like green bean and bell pepper so most
definitely
some relationship between
location
and wine sensory so we did feel that we
were able to
verify some of these sub-appellations
so in terms of these cabernet and
riesling studies um
we felt that there were some clear
relationships between uh things like
soil and vine water status
as well as uh and things such as
free and bound terpenes and riesling and
some of the phenolic analytes and
cabernet franc and i think that's really
the one major take-home message and i
think the other one is is that there was
nice temporal stability from year to
year
with a lot of these relationships so if
you can get in there and you can get
some data
you can have something that probably is
going to repeat itself year after year
so i'm going to probably take a couple
more minutes if i may and i think i can
finish off
i just wanted to make a couple of
mentions of
some of this remote sensing work that we
did
using
riesling and
pinot noir so
similar projects looking at uh
soil moisture
leaf water potential but we had the
added set of data and that we were doing
a whole lot of flyovers and collecting
some
spectral reflectance data
as a result of the flyovers
and
this is one place this was the 30 bench
vineyards
consisted of a whole series of these
sub-blocks that we were able to
delineate
this was a 25-acre riesling block we
collected about 520
vines or
collected data from 520 vines so a lot
of work
and collected things like soil moisture
every year and leaf water potential and
so on and so forth so we were getting
some nice
temporal stability at least three out of
four years for soil moisture 2009 never
stopped raining and so we
didn't see that nice temporal stability
when
we got to 2009
and
the same goes for leaf water potential
we're seeing the low leaf water
potential here in that that triangle
zone
and 2009 not so much
all right i think i better
finish this up and so what i'd like to
do is i'm just going to
skip ahead to the the end because we've
got some work
that's ongoing that we're where we're
looking at the terroir winter hardiness
and that's mary jaczynski's project
so i'm just going to skip ahead about
three or four slides to that
and then i can
take some questions
okay so with this what we're doing is
we're essentially mapping winter
hardiness
and looking at lt50 values
lethal temperature 50 values and seeing
how they might relate to things like
soil moisture and leaf water potential
the hypothesis being is that we would
find lower
lt50 values in zones of vineyards that
had
somewhat lower soil moisture during the
growing season
and
lower leaf water potential so maybe
touching on almost water stress
and yes indeed we were finding in a lot
of these vineyards that there was
a relationship between
soil moisture leaf water potential and
lt 50 in a great many of these vineyards
oh that's a good question and it
it's going to differ from
vineyard to vineyard
roughly minus
19 minus 26
are there abouts
c yeah c
and here's another example we can see
this low yielding area
is also associated with low lt 50 values
and so we're finding that not just that
but also
associated with higher anthocyanins and
higher phenolics so there's also the
quality benefit that comes along with
this
okay and we're finding that there's a
temporal effect as well and we're
finding that
a zone of low lt 50 expands as you move
into winter and as those vines acclimate
a little bit more
and then it will shrink again if you're
starting to
look at lt 50 values in late february or
early march so you're seeing that
de-acclimation
effect and you're seeing a a change in
the the size of these lt50 patterns
okay i think i can skip over that one
and just kind of go over to uh to
conclusions
um
so i would say that geomatics has
allowed us to to conclude that uh
uh that this terroir effect is uh
associated with things such as
soil and vine water status and uh to
some extent also
yield and possibly vine size i think
those things probably account for a
large
percentage of the terroir effect
these technologies have also allowed us
to to verify and validate
sub-appellations within the niagara
region
and i think that
coupled with remote sensing we might be
able to help
growers delineate and define some
sub-blocks that they might be able to
use for for economic gain
i'm hoping that this
work will also allow us
over a period of years to
be able to show growers
high and low risk
winter injury areas within their their
vineyard blocks that might mean that
they can
cluster thin portions of vineyard blocks
in order to enhance winter hardiness for
instance
i i think the last thing to mention and
that is is that
any vineyard variable can be mapped
and
any
vineyard variable can be
uh looked at in terms of its spatial
variability and in terms of its uh
spatial correlation with other variables
so
whether it's a whole bunch of soil
variables and things like that you can
relate those with
things that are going to
mean money for you yield fruit
composition and things of that nature
so i think with that i better
stop
i've gone over a few minutes and
i'd like to save some time for questions
so thank you
i i don't know if i've
worked in a vineyard where uh
i i would see a five dollar section
maybe a fifteen dollar section
and most definitely there's some
areas or zones within those vineyards
where they would
um
probably be able to create a 35 or 40
but yeah i i agree with you i think that
uh
some effort would have to be made to
bring up the potential value of that
low value zone
before i'd start thinking about
selling that 40 bottle
okay
uh good question with the uh
um destructive sampling we were usually
looking at uh
a rate of um
75 to 100 vines to the hectare
and uh generally in a
a grid try to look at it something like
an eight by eight meter grid or
something of that nature
it's a big area yeah
um
that one block we had uh
25 acres and we had about 500 vines that
we
took from that
25 acres so yeah i think you're always
trying to uh
create that balance between well
how much have i got time to do
and
how detailed can i get
and make sure that i've got something
that i have full confidence in
and so yeah we've we figured around 75
to 100 per hectare
or in some cases more well all of all of
our
yield maps that was all
from
hand harvested
but there was
that was joe davenport's
data from washington where she had the
the machine so that would have been uh
continuous
uh that's a good question and that's
certainly what
bramley and some of those guys have been
uh trying to do in australia is to
do some of these flyovers or
use greenseeker in order to get
ndvi maps
and
associate those with
either yield or or vine size or both and
and they have been fairly successful in
doing that
and
generally i i skipped over a few of
those slides but uh
we were quite successful actually in uh
seeing some nice relationships between
ndvi and yield and vine size and uh yeah
so i think that's possible
um there also seem to be some nice
relationships between ndvi and uh
things like leaf water potential
and and bricks and uh and color and
things like that
the the data that i've seen from our lab
and and others seem seem to indicate
that there is a nice correlation there
so yeah if you can get a green seeker or
something like that i think you're all
set okay thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu